on le sait si les règles du premier
confinement en mars dernier avait été
globalement respectée ce second
confinement ne prend pas le même chemin
comme on a pu le constater avec ses
scènes de la vie quotidienne ou les
gestes barrières semblent absents on
oublie la distanciation sociale mais si
certains ne boira pas le masson sortent
dans la rue avec de fausses attestations
le vrai problème de ce second
confinement et bien sûr le cluster ces
rassemblements clandestins de plusieurs
dizaines de personnes qui se mélangent
et ne respecte aucune règle sanitaire
les 20 ans font qu on a forcément envie
de faire sortir ce week-end c'est un
cluster à joinville le pont qui a fait
parler un cluster de plus de 300
personnes réunies pour une fête
clandestine mais en plus d'enfreindre
les règles du confinement
à l'arrivée des forces de l'ordre les
invités se sont tout bonnement rebeller
des échauffourées ont éclaté jets de
bouteilles de la part des invités
visiblement très excité contre grenade
de désencerclement de la part des
policiers
la du karaté inconscient de cette fête
aujourd'hui tout le monde est inquiet
après la découverte d'un cas de covile
positive parmi les invités un cluster en
puissance qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences dramatiques
le maire de joinville-le-pont olivier
donne a tenu à condamner cet acte
ces criminels ce qui s'est passé parce
qu potentiellement ce sont des familles
qui vont se contaminer le propriétaire
du pavillon et organisateur de la soirée
ainsi qu'une troisième personne ont été
placés en garde à vue dimanche
ce soir aidé à belhaj policiers du
val-de-marne va tout nous raconter sur
cette folle soirée alors soirées
clandestines à joinville-le-pont les
organisateurs sont ils des criminels
alors nicolas pernikoff déjà avant qu'on
écoute regardez là je vous dit oui dit
oui aujourd'hui on va voir la réponse
tout de suite oui et bien sûr que les
organisateurs sont criminels on est en
période de confinement on va pas
commencer à faire des soirées en plus
ils le font depuis le premier
confinement tous les voisins en ont
marre si un problème avec 6 a eu un
problème lors de cette soirée au moment
où la police est intervenue
on aurait encore dit que c'était à cause
de la prise je viens à un moment donné
il faut arrêter cette incivilité on vous
demande à tous d'être confiné donc
respectée sur sentiment [ __ ] alors
ridha belhaj et avec mercy reda
secrétaire départemental sgp police du
val-de-marne est bien sûr joinville le
pont c'est dans le val demain qu'est ce
qui s'est passé exactement
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi vers 2
heures du matin les collègues du val de
marne ont été appelés pour une
bagarre entre une centaine d'individus
dans un pavillon alors alors c'était
pour une bagarre parce que je me suis
dit au départ c'est il y avait tellement
de bruit les gens ont dû appeler pour le
bruit en fait parce que c'est vrai
qu'une spect à 300 400 personnes et
énormément de bruit mais là c'était pour
une bagarre à la bagarre générale d'une
heure entre une centaine d'individus
d'accord et donc les collègues une fois
arrivés sur place ils ont été non pas
tout de suite été identifiées et une
fois qu'ils ont été identifiés par les
individus qui se battait au fond d'eux
au fond du loft
en fait c'est un loft avec piscine
aménagée en discothèque
d'accord ils ont été pris à partie
d'accord alors donc ils vont alors il
paraît que voilà aucune consigne était
respectée
c'est pas la première fois comme vous
l'avez dit nicolas pernikoff comment ça
se fait qu'on n'a pas su avant il y
avait des fêtes comme ça dans cette dans
ce loft écouter dans le val de marne
c'est la première fois qu'on nous
signale ce genre de méfaits en général
on a des difficultés dans les quartiers
difficiles avec les rassemblements de
jeunes voyous comme on dit dans notre
jargon
mais là en l'occurrence il y avait eu
deux interventions et une main courante
mais de l'extérieur il n'y avait pas de
tapage donc nous comme on n'a pas comme
c'est un lieu privé on n'a pas le droit
de s'introduire comme ça c'était assez
bien sécurisé donc on ne pouvait pas
accéder
alors est ce qu'on en sait plus sur le
profil de l'organisateur s'est il
organisait plusieurs soirs où c'était
vraiment il a organisé que cette soirée
c'était ponctuel
écoutez là il ya encore une enquête en
four il ya le propriétaire qui s'est
présenté samedi soir aux services de
police il a été placé en garde à vue
l'accord avait l'organisateur qui a été
placé en garde à vue dimanche également
et je crois le corps gras organisateurs
pardon dimanche au centre alors vous
allez nous dire ce qu'il risque dans un
instant et si vous pensez vous aussi
qu'il s'agit d'un acte criminel pour
vous c'est oui oh oui c'est un acte
criminel parce qu'ils ne respectent pas
mais je vous pose une question vous qu
est bon sur le terrain
est ce que par rapport au premier
confinement est ce que vous été
confronté à des soirées comme celle là
est ce qu'il ya eu non pas dans donc
pour moi c'est jeune c'est très mal ce
qu'ils ont fait mais je pense que la
faute
elle est aussi en partie du gouvernement
on n'a qu'à nous confiner à 100% ou pas
la ccd demi mesure donc je pense que les
en sort et d'organiser un mot non non
non non débutée
même si je vous aime beaucoup c'est la
lie à un truc qui est clair c'est pas de
rassemblement de plus de dix personnes
dans une maison en sauna ça c'est clair
ça on peut pas être plus clair là dessus
qu'est ce qu'ils risquent qu'est ce qui
risque pour l'instant parce que quand
vous traitez une affaire judiciaire
comme ça vous prenez le global on sait
dakar l'instant les organisateurs et
demi il risque une mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui et risques du travail
dissimulé
donc ça c'est les délits après les gens
qui étaient sur place ils risquent des
amendes pour le non-respect du
confinement au travail dissimulé ses
ventes d'alcool
d'accord ils ont vendu des tables-bancs
l'alcool alors ils ont vendu des terres
d'accord ils demandent où il est habité
sur internet d'abord d'accord alors est
ce que pour vous il s'agit de criminels
ça je sais pas moi de juger
moi ce que je peux dire c'est que c'est
des gens qui sont organisés qui
profitent du fermeture des boîtes de la
fermeture des boîtes de nuit pour
organiser des soirées privées comme l'a
dit monsieur vous avez la table c'était
250 euros pour deux personnes et 500
euros pour 5 personnes sans la boisson
donc voilà il vous à leur petit business
quoi alors oui guillaume
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on arrête de
faire les hypocrites mais on est tous là
s'offusquer pour le moindre geste
barrière qui est pas respectée alors que
dans la vraie ni personne ne respecte
totalement les gestes barrière qu'à 60%
des filiales montagne allemand des
barrières les de 20 entre 20 et 30 ans
le week-end ils sortent tous le vendredi
le samedi donc c'est bien de parler de
la théorie dst barriac ses terres mais
la réalité c'est que plus personne n'est
réellement confiné à 100 % aujourd'hui
celles ci ne sont pas éternels à part
les violences que moi je cautionne pas
mais non c'est pas des criminels
une elle est beaucoup trop fort mais
c'est vrai que je comprends même pas
qu'on en arrive là en fait c'est
beaucoup fin d'année je suis désolé
c'est criminel il faut rajouter en
puissance c'est à dire qu'en fait ça va
être une chaîne
ces gens là vont pouvoir peut-être voir
leurs grands parents
il y en a 1 positif ils étaient quand
même venus tout sur 300 mètres carrés
ils étaient 300 à 400 lui même une heure
les barrières sociales
donc ce sont des criminels en puissance
ils vont peut-être le donner à quelqu'un
qui va mourir je suis radin c'est
gravissime
non mais moi je trouve ça idiot
irresponsable inconscient alors
effectivement tu dis pas qu on veut mais
non il n'ya qu'un kayak un cas mais je
te rappelle qu au one c'est reparti
parce qu'il ya eu un cas mais ce gars
dans une discothèque a contaminé
des dizaines et des centaines de
personnes donc c'est complètement à 20
ans ne pas pouvoir sortir et voir ces
cessions annoncées insupporte à l'âme et
la mort c'est vrai que non mais c'est
pas trop d'amis non plus bas c'est bon
c'est bon
non j'ai déjà fait un nom et puis en
plus si jamais il ya un grand intérêt si
ça reparte et ce sera non mais ça c'est
pas encore reculer pour mieux savoir ce
qu'en pensent ses téléspectateurs les
chéris regardez oui à 74% un nom à 26%
guillaume tu peux pas confondre une fête
avec deux trois potes et personne n'a tu
mets super contaminateur tu mets en
l'air la vie de super contaminateur et
ça donne ça commence depuis août je
croise à commencer depuis août et sa
conduite depuis deux trois mois et cinq
écoles à l'école
désolé mais d'être quand même tous des
faux cul parce que on se plaint pour
pour les libraires ou les restaurateurs
les boîtes de nuit peuvent plus beau
senna chez moi aidez moi
donc maintenant il suffit d'aller créer
une boîte de nuit où tu me payer 150 ans
mais c'est en réaction à sa qui a un peu
partout autour de chez toi lama invité
dans un club ce week end je vous dis la
vérité
le bénin ims y avait 800 personnes je
n'y suis pas allé j'ai dit non mais là
vous avez vous avez un nombre de boîtes
de nuit quand même qui ont fait faillite
ah oui c'est rien c'est incroyable
exactement